olivier ferrand estime que sa stratégie
était la bonne un millier de centres de
vaccination sont ouverts
il y aura selon lui de 1,3 à 1,4
millions de français vaccinés d'ici la
fin janvier
9 millions d'ici la fin du mois de mars
et tous les français à la fin août mais
cela si et seulement si les autorités
européennes valide tous les vaccins
commandés par la france alors olivier
ferrand a expliqué que aujourd'hui la
pression sanitaire est forte
la tension hospitalière l'est tout
autant il ya des transferts de malades
mais que le couvre-feu semble être
efficace en tout cas on ne sait pas s'il
est suffisamment il pourrait aussi y
avoir un scénario à l'anglais je vous
propose d'écouter le ministre
si nous devions constater qu'ils
auraient davantage de variants anglais
et que nous étions sur une pente de
épidémique al anglaise par exemple ou si
nous constations que malgré le
couvre-feu à 18 heures la pression
sanitaire la saturation des hôpitaux de
fait augmenté alors nous pourrions être
amenés à prendre des mesures plus dures
telles que celles que les français ont
déjà connu pendant l'automne c'est à
dire ça peut aller jusqu'à un
confinement si la situation devait
l'exiger alors une nuance toutefois si
un confinement devrait se produire les
écoles resteraient ouvertes car selon
olivier ferrand le protocole sanitaire
que l'on déploie est efficace concernant
les stations de ski elles ne rouvriront
pas début février et peut-être pas du
tout en février a dit olivier ferrand
mais les emplois la montagne seront
aidés et puis il n'y a pas de date
annoncée pour la réouverture des bars et
des restaurants
il y à un nouveau geste barrière a
signalé le haut conseil en santé
publique a estimé qu'à cause du variant
il fallait désormais respecter une
distance de 2 mètres avec une personne
sans masque pour ne pas être contaminé
et puis au niveau des masques aussi une
annonce désormais seuls ceux de
catégorie 1 serait suffisamment efficace
les autres dits de catégorie 2 les
masques artisanaux faits en tissu à la
maison et bien ne serait pas assez
protecteur et pour remédier à cela des
milliers de masques seront envoyés aux
personnes en difficulté voilà pas de
scoop sur les annonces d'olive et rome
et une foule de petites informations à
retenir